these first couple of questions are the
basic ones were just evaluating things
do you remember your laws these ones
taken a little bit further because
they're still remembering laws but it's
like it's algebra like I can't just
evaluate numbers when I see them okay so
there's that
adding the extra layer not a huge one
but it is there that's why they're sort
of suit carries so let's see how your
memory is and how you're how comfortably
you're starting to feel with this new
kind of arithmetic with laws so someone
give me suggestion not an answer but a
first sign of working for question one
someone that you take it yeah go ahead
so you're saying I'm gonna have log base
a of 32 off to excellent okay good pick
you who wants to give me a next step
where do we go from here because we've
used the power lot we've used it twice
to bring them in front doesn't you
combine the logs together okay the
coolest addition you multiply that's it
so this 32 and this to wait they're
going to multiply together to become 264
right fantastic and then once you've got
this point everything's folded down into
one log perfect 8 to the power of
something is 64 2 to 8 times 8 is 64 but
the power of interested it is and
squaring it okay so here we go
never to it let's have a look excuse me
again suggestion for a first step of
working someone hasn't said anything yet
yeah not actually no yeah said something
we can come ID
that's right someone else have an
opportunity see Robbie you got anywhere
on this question yeah okay that's
alright that's alright come down and
check all right here you go yeah okay
right I'll give you a hand okay enjoy
you can teach me all right yeah you can
see here I look at these things and I
think about what can I work with first
okay now the things screaming that to me
is I've thinks in brackets but normal
order of operations I should deal with
things in brackets first right so I got
two logs I'm adding them together just
like this net we just did here adding
together means we multiply those things
in
so that log base 3 of 270 he's hanging
at the front haven't done anything to
him yet but when I subtract what I'm
subtracting here is log base 3 of 2
times 5 which is 10 okay
so log base 3 of 10 great now I've
turned 3 logs into 2 or give me a next
step I can't fantastic just like we saw
adding turns into multiplication
subtraction turns into division right
you see how important it was and how
glad I was to be able to do inverse
functions and then leading to this
because all the investors appear
everywhere right so I'm going to have
log base 3 off 270 divided by 10 which
is 27 and again just like at this point
I'm down to 1 log 3 ^ what will give me
27 3 cubed right so 3 is just it okay
all right now when we get to question 3
because we can't do this some these
steps here steps like this like oh
that's a number I recognize like knows
what this number is
okay you just have to be a little more
crafty okay so for instance excuse me
you can see here I've got some choices
as to how I want to simplify this I've
got the power log involved right behind
that good morning I'm gonna bring this
power out the front so there or
alternatively I could take this the
coefficient that's what we call that
number at the front and I can turn the
into the power which would you prefer to
do so you want to take this 3 and put it
up should we try that all right so I'm
gonna get log base a of a squared and
we'll leave that guy there plus log base
a of the 3 is gonna come out it'll be 8
cubed right okay now when I add together
logs we've already established this I
multiply these guys here that guy and
that guy right so I'm gonna go in log
base a of index plus a squared times a
cubed is
the power of five like so okay so now I
can either do this next part in one or
two steps what am I gonna do with these
five de pesca I can bring that out the
front five right and then say okay
what's left is log base a of a which is
just one so that's just fine okay yes
put on pause for a second I want to take
your line of which line are you
referring to like the original question
yeah okay so what will you suggest you
doing you with what you see behind do
you mean like that's the coefficient
yeah okay good bye like just pause I'm
gonna take your own mind of are you
gonna send it right now I said I made it
be point like oh why do we do notation
and use new words and that kind of thing
it's because it allows us to stir out
things more finely right it's like yeah
kind of half of us know what you mean by
saying behind but only half of us then
the other half think you mean they're
right which is what I thought
so therefore when we use words like
coefficient or power it's like and now
we all know what we're talking about
this to power okay okay good now I've
taken the - you are pretty here now when
I do that
is one
and on the other side love
like one against
yeah that's right now just in case you
didn't quite catch everybody's remember
I said at the beginning we have two
choices right we can turn everything
into these powers up here or we can turn
everything into coefficients now that's
what areum was suggesting the instead of
going up to the a cubes we're saying we
met three there then where it is and do
this now I'm gonna suggest even though
we are going to get the same answer this
is probably ever so slightly quicker
than what you were doing before
because you can see here what I had to
do was I had to turn them into powers
and then I kind of had to turn them back
it was fine we can do it right but it's
like well if I can choose less steps
rather than more steps I'll choose less
that was not immediately apparent when
we first started and it didn't matter in
a sense like we still got that all good
right but as you start doing more of
these yah okay I think I'm gonna choose
these kinds of strategies rather than
these ones because they tend to be
quicker and therefore this error prone
okay so happy times those are both great
solutions last question okay excuse me
you keeping that in the back of your
mind right that uh we've just
established that generally getting that
number at the front is a good idea okay
what would you like to do with question
four who wants to give me a first-line
way yeah
okay so this this um this is up two
steps or literature spine relax is
really we want everything in the next
form right so that's X the power of our
Father so if that's to have a half I can
put that half at the front right thumbs
up okay what I do at the next clip we're
gonna keep careful right I've got a red
X there so the index is our half here I
have an X on the denominator so what's
the index that puts a number on the
denominator it's it's negative right
it's a negative one you cross the line
change the sign okay so therefore I've
got subtraction and then there's a
double negative right of log a X in fact
that was just what about more laws
excuse me that when you've got a
fraction here you can turn it upside
down take the reciprocal and step with
minus sign because that won't give you
and that's the effect that index has
what happens this double negative
it just becomes a plus so I've got half
that thing whatever it is plus one of
them half for something plus a whole of
something is well it's one and a half of
that thing or three on two
so I would just write this as three on
to do so okay
now at this point I'm kind of done like
I don't know what log base a of X is
they don't give me any values I could I
suppose I could put this up here in the
tower but I think you'd be hard-pressed
to find someone who would say it's
simpler to have something raised to some
reader looking power versus just x
number like a x okay so I think at this
point we're finished alright any
questions on those
so wait you could be on three yes sure
okay so here what about here right even
though there's like all of this replay
logarithm Deslauriers of that like this
is just algebra and collecting like
terms okay it's just collecting like
terms and the like terms I've got our
log base a of X here and log base a of X
here so if I gave you something that
simple like half M plus n right that's
like well okay how many M's do I have
the ends well I've got one here and I've
got half of what here so I've got one
and a half of them in total which is
just three up to okay if you wanted to I
suppose you could write that as this
divided by 2 and this is 2 lots of them
divided by 2 and then you get them on a
common denominator I don't think that's
really necessary good question
anyone else want to clarify the question
3
how do I get that yeah yeah sure okay
sir again be careful just hang the
algebra it's not that much more
complicated but it's just that extra a
little bit where from here to here I
think we can all see that 432 nor -
they're going to multiply to be the 64th
you're all ok with that
yeah but here that a squared the a cube
they're doing exactly the same thing
except when you multiply them together a
squared times a cubed the illnesses and
so it's a ^ 2 + 3 so just like we would
state me in explore like this okay like
so so here's my 2 + 3 my M + M which is
5 so it's worth mentioning like this is
just another reason why I probably this
sum this path this method through the
question is quicker right cuz you don't
have to worry about your next laws it is
I'm just doing two or something times 2
plus 3 or something I can add 2 & 3
like that's just fine okay so that's why
probably I would prefer that even though
you you did get the same answer